العربيه ما زالت تواكب اصول رعايه من دول
عده قادمين من السودان قبل قليل كنا نرصد
ثلاث سفن عسكريه سفينتين صينيتين عسكريتين
وصلتي الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وتحمل قرابه
670 من رعايا الصين وكذلك السفينه الثالثه
هي سفينه هنديه وتحمل قرابه الميئتين
وخمسه وتسعين شخص هؤلاء الدفعه الاخيره من
رعايه الصين هم يقومون بانهاء اجراءاتهم
عبر المنصات الخاصه والكونترات الخاصه في
صاله القدوم في ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا في
المنطقه الخاصه بالجوازات السعوديه للحديث
اكثر ينضم معي الرائد حامد الحارثي وهو
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجوازات
السعوديه هنا في المنطقه الغربيه مرحبا بك
رائد حامد دعنا نتحدث اولا يعني الوضع
الذي يحدث الان وضع كحاله طارئه
لابد ان يكون هناك خطه طوارئ لديكم لو
نتحدث عنها بالبدايه انا من بدايه ارحب
فيك وفي الساده المشاهدين امتدادا للجهود
المبذوله التي تقدمها حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لاجلاء المواطنين ورعايا
الدول المديريه العامه للجوازات سخرت كافه
الامكانات لاستقبال هؤلاء المواطنين
والرعايه وانهاء وانهاء اجراءات دخولهم في
وقت قياسي وكذلك بسهوله
هنالك متابعه واشراف على مدار 24 ساعه من
قبل القيادات القطاع وذلك للاطلاع على سير
العمل ومعالجه ما يتطلب معالجته بشكل فوري
وذلك تعزيزا للدور الذي تقوم به المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طيب يعني خلال الثلاث
ايام الماضيه الكاميرا العربيه كانت ترصد
تزايد في اعداد الرعايه يوم امس كان 400
اليوم الف
شخص من رعايه الصين والهند يوم امس بعثه
الامم المتحده ايضا هناك عمليات اجلاء
لمواطنين قرابه
2500 كيف تقومون بتسخير الجهود هنا او
الاعداد بالنسبه
لضباط الصف والمنصات الخاصه بنهاء
الاجراءات القدوم المديريه العامه
للجوازات الممثله في جوازات منطقه مكه
المكرمه تستقبل المواطنين ورعايه الدول عن
طريق ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي تم دعم هذه
المنطقه بالاعداد اللازمه بالتقنيه
الحديثه وذلك لانهاء الاجراءات ايضا
يتم معالجه اوضاع القادمين الذين لا
يحملون تاشيرات ولا يحملون جوازات سفر نعم
وذلك
لا يحملون جوازات وتاشيرات ماذا ما هو
الحال به
تتم
تتم معالجه اوضاعهم
بمنحهم تاشيرات نعم
خلينا يعني نقوم بعمليه انت تذكرت فكره
التقنيات ونشاهد فعلا اخذ العلامات
الحيويه وكذلك نهائي الاجراءات نتحدث عن
المده يعني نتكلم اليوم عن الف هل ينتظرون
ساعات طوال المده التي يتم انهاء فيها هذه
الاجراءات نعم يتم اخذ الخصائص الحيويه
وانهاء اجراءات دخول القادمين في مده لا
تتجاوز العشرين ثانيه عشرين ثانيه لكل شخص
يعني تكون العمليه اسهل واسرع صحيح شكرا
لك الرائد حمد اذا كان هذا حديث الرائد
حمد الحارثي وهو المتحدث باسم الجوازات
السعوديه هنا في المنطقه الغربيه وهذه
احدى السيدات التي قدمت من الصين اول لقتي
قدمت من السودان من رعايا الصين تقوم
بانهاء خصائصه الحيويه وكذلك ايضا اخذ
المعلومات الاخيره والتاكد من المعلومات
الاخيره من موظف الجوازات هناك ايضا كما
تحدث حمد الحارثي ان الذين الذين ليس
لديهم تاشيرات يمنح لهم تاشيرات سريعه حتى
يتم مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم هنا تتضح ايضا
عمليه شرح موظفه للجوازات الذين يتحدثون
بعده لغات
يقوم بشرح لاحد الرعايه الصين في وضع
اصابعه تظهر هذه العلامات الحيويه كما
نشاهدها الان هذه تجربه حيه ترصدها كاميرا
العربيه
لوضع او
توضيح واظهار العلامات الحيويه من خلال
البصمه واظهار صورته او اخذ لقطه لصورته
وكذلك بياناته فهناك بعض الاشخاص الذين
ليس لهم تاشيرات ولكن تمنح لهم تاشيرات
عاجله وسريعه حتى يتم مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم بسلام لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات